[Musique]
un virus créé en laboratoire l'industrie
pharmaceutique responsable de sa
propagation
une pandémie liée à la 5g c'est le genre
dénoncé conspirationnistes que des
chercheurs de l'université de sherbrooke
ont présenté à des participants résultat
près de 18 pour cent des canadiens il y
adhérer en juin dernier fait quand même
beaucoup parce que ça va être un peu de
temps les gens ont très rapidement
commencer à croire à des complots liela
coville
mais c'est peu quand on regarde pas dans
nos deux pays parce que les chercheurs
ont sondé 1500 personnes par pays
aux philippines le taux d'adhésion
énoncé complotistes était de 47 7% 35,9
% en angleterre et de 34 7% aux
états-unis le canada s'en sort donc bien
une différence qui s'expliquerait
notamment par la confiance de la
population envers les institutions
on va vraiment allié avec la méfiance
donc moins gens font confiance aux
autorités font par les autorités de
santé publique le gouvernement les
médias nous les chercheurs avaient plus
qui ont tendance à aller chercher des
réponses ailleurs j'ai mes yeux du monde
the brick du nouveau une perte de
confiance qui les posent aussi à
s'informer sont les médias sociaux et le
problème c'est que sur internet on peut
trouver une réponse à tous qui va dans
tous les sens on peut très facilement se
convaincre qu'on avait raison depuis le
début en sciences on essaie d'éviter ça
se résume à motiver long depuis
l'obligation du port du masque au québec
les manifestations contre les mesures
sanitaires se sont multipliés entre
autres à montréal de la faire une
manifestation où on n'a pas de masque
puis après ça ces gens là ils vont où
ils vont chez eux peut-être qu'ils ont
des enfants qui vont à l'école
après ça peut-être que soyons super
baker amis je trouve ça irresponsable et
ses dépôts de ça dont on a besoin en ce
moment
les messages sont souvent disparates et
ponctué 10 des complotistes
je pense que comme étant un mouvement
monolithique tout le monde la dda croit
la même chose
difficile de dresser le profil type du
conspirationnistes mais les chercheurs
ont les jeunes sous leur lot
et si jacques andré charbonneau raid
canada mon frère